oh come on up any redness a DJ I Sokka
commercial teach vidcam sala sono stanca
stanka see cozy cozy okay la prossima
settimana this thing yep no never can
channel spring break not on camera how's
that in Nevada allora bell she's some
gigantic pascua a stair Mexico what does
it differently for me happiest is
something happening today we're not
going to introduce a new vocabulary but
it is that we practice to have to talk
about ourselves and to talk about job
you're studying whatever you're doing so
a pretty dialogue yeah the primaries is
a king so this is I think you who you
can start with that all right just it
well he just have pieces of
conversations it's difficult to
understand but idea is that there are
two friends meet and one of the friends
is
with another person who is for Cathy so
they're going to use themselves where
they come from what we do in any make
plans for the evening we are only three
characters so i will write the name of
each character and a post it on then you
can you please okay so the first we have
first small piece of conversation is
such a number one hello we're chasing
camasta been 80 named Cassie acuesta mia
cugina Jane or Johnny hahahaha okay so
be a better each it is the name cheap
very cheap let's invite you down I mean
you spell it as in in the same way in
English but the pronunciation is
different so yes yeah we are to each
athlete other way to anyone so difficult
we are putting a cherry okay let's tie
game hey tell the kidney converse day Oh
Veneto Benghazi questa a mia cugina Jane
Chow Kon Tiki commented young men gay
emoji to meet llamo Mateo catch it eph
it a mu
take over jpn a diva the Boston in
Massachusetts cuz our fire a Boston who
cuz I study is a woman is a biologist
yours you're studying biology not the
bio how's our boy finds condo teal re
already been buried Yolo Jamboree yoga
what's this part of conversation what
are they come I found out that I want to
be a marine biologist lady when I grow
again it's right what do you understand
from this conversation I'm introducing
basically kind of making an icebreaker
get something about how Jane is from
Massachusetts and Boston and then they
talk a little bit about a small talk
about you doing what he studies their
biology you want to be marine biologist
okay great so we can have a new better
each other Oh first thing he says is
interesante what does it mean
interesting and then so he was talking
with Jane how he talks to be a teacher
and says hey too rare creature gossip I
a desk so what does it mean right now
what do you do adesso means now adesso
understood so maybe they're friends that
haven't seen each other for a while so
he's asking her what do you do now
because a fight ah days and she answers
stop chill condo lavoro
for where yes so chill come let me write
this down it's the word [ __ ] car sure
sure sure busca positive in Mandarin
course I searching searching for
searching the war zone haha gen console
Gavin so check out and so chin java chip
ha ha ha hey library so she says scotch
it can go oh come oh yeah Thank answers
business pin it in Boca are you in Bocca
al Lupo and the wolf smell yes good luck
which means good luck yes I had that
last semester what's fast I was just
wishing good luck in the test vodka is
how new pop is war so little is in mouth
of the wolf Alex to the auto engine area
right
so what does it mean ice to be a top
hollyoaks to you start a new engine yes
engineering in via yes and then she
answer six so not cool engineering
mechanical mechanical so what what is
there yeah mechanical engineer hey john
and ann and she asking a to look it's
okay yeah hi 2k5 lovato in una tienda de
program mud Sione yeah he works in the
company who at the end up at the end in
balance to come my programming company
good okay now we have Jane and Beth
reaches this point James a little bit
bored keep talking and so she's going to
ask I heard a cheese cydia yes she's in
yeah cuz I acedia oh yes oh you're Missy
800 little ladies I seat myself is
reflexive that's why we have cheap
scindia cheese
yeah check friendly I'm an aperitivo
endocardium watch n Christina coochie
coochie 90m Aviva that I fever so when
she got party sent unload so a lot of
you so she said yeah mom certo friend
yahoo aperitivo we take and edit evo 8
top with the stubble yeah after then I'm
yamaha China China so you see in the
world China it's like chit karda to
write a check Tina Tina check baby sing
on key cucina duty so cute she never
does any good let's go kick and the
answer is puccinia too deep in CA meant
oh yeah all together MP bah alright yeah
ok let's try once more okay good job
averey check our side
no Jane haha ok so next round we have
gained and mcdowell I don't care what
let's do get it done bein so America
americana the UN Jane Jane Jane is the
Boston in Massachusetts Oh go Sofia boss
Oh still you ah courses to d I'll be all
alone here Yolo Jia Jia Jia cuz I boy I
fire my look another all right permits
glory deaf and Terry una pelota marina
oh so for a regulatory per day for a
given palette def given Hara una una
yoga Peralta Marina marina now we have
master and petition which are
interesante to
che cosa fire adesso so check gondolas
water Bennett in bocca lupo artist
Giotto in henna in henan area I staccato
ingenious Yemen Jamie area Jania 6
tohno-kun ingénierie mechanical I told
KFI lovato in una tienda de programacion
last part we have jada and Redd mission
was to choose know yet check out free me
llamo young would happen tebow a doctor
and the animal channel yeah she's young
teto Griffith free premium premium 00
after a tivo a dopo and the ammo and
chain cuchini mo 2t in seeming a viewer
yes sir I'm llamo